hello everyone 2019 is almost a rap
cloud gaming is gonna be a huge topic
next year but it's kind of already a big
topic this year Google is following the
footsteps of many others but making a
huge splash at least they want to with
stadia Michael and I have been twin
around with it for four days yo got our
got our founders editions here yeah we
have a lot to talk about but one thing
we have to caveat this with is that
these really aren't our final
impressions
you know the founders edition what the
games are gonna be available how all the
tech is gonna work that stuff is gonna
change the day after this video goes
live so these are our initial
impressions based on pre-release state
of things and we'll be back with more to
say about things once they launch
properly yeah stadia is not in its final
form even at launch because there's
still a lot of features that are going
to be implemented a lot more games that
are going to be launched gradually but
yeah so yeah like you said this is the
this is a a pre-release impressions of
Google Stadium yep and we've got a bunch
of lists regarding the stuff that's
gonna come later on in this video so
hang tight but first let's look at some
gameplay let's mix it up
[Music]
so what you just saw is a sample of the
studio gameplay that we've been enjoying
or trying to enjoy for the past few days
and I say that because stadia is pretty
complicated it is yeah it's advanced but
it's not so easy yeah there's there's a
lot of small things that you need to
work around to really get to the meat of
what stadia is I think that you know
we're gonna get into the different ways
that you can enter the stadia app
because there's a you can use your pixel
phones for now yeah chromecast ultra and
you can do it through a Chrome browser
but yeah there's it's it's kind of
complicated you know through a Chrome
browser you can only for now you can
only do up to 1080p and it's not the
best quality but it does work and I
think that's the most intuitive way to
play stadia games you just go to the the
website login to your account and boom
you're ready to launch a game in your
Chrome browser and I think that that's
that's kind of my favorite way to engage
with it but yes your overall opinion
this far know what's your what's your
what's your like back in the box quote
for this good or bad
cool boy that's it says it all yeah it's
okay and it's it's different aspects of
it because going into this my main
concern was input lag and I think that
when I played that when I'm playing
destiny I think that I I do feel it
playing keyboard and mouse controls
especially with a first-person shooter
and I do feel that with destiny to play
Mortal Kombat 11 is actually kind of
impressive with I mean it is a slower
fighting game there are options to
tinker with input windows so it's a game
a fighting game that works really well
for this even if there is a smidge of
input lag so I'm been impressed on that
front that being said I am playing
mainly through a wired connection so
it's best conditions possible for this
thing I think what surprised me from the
flip side is how much I noticed image
compression yeah
going into this I was my meow like I
said my main concern input lags but now
I'm looking at this thing and I'm
playing like I said in the best
conditions possible and I'm noticing a
lot of
image compression and I have a decent
monitor a good connection and I have
this thing set to play in 1080p and I am
noticing those things so you're not
gonna get the the best looking image out
there right and I think for me the big
question is you know because we are
people who play games normally on
consoles and PC you are as well for the
most part we're assuming you know we are
people that Google is trying to you know
court as an option for gaming and
everything I've played so far I just had
this nagging feeling like I think I'd
rather play it somewhere else now as you
were mentioning like there are some
obvious you know advantages to using
stadia totally agree opening up games on
a browser tab is like one of those
things just like ah that's so cool but
yeah there are issues right I mean even
even though I don't expect it to be
absolutely perfect I'd be lying myself
if I said yeah this is this is what I
look for in a modern gaming experience
it's their sacrifices basically and
there are a lot of complications as well
which we'll get into but you know not
everything is as easy as you might think
given the state of modern technology
even given the state of Google's own
ecosystem of hardware so for example we
know one of the most frustrating things
for me is someone who has a Google home
router and the chromecast ultra is you
know used as the same home app on your
cell phone as the router that I have
does I was unable to make the to
communicate with each other now that's
given the fact that I had set up my
chromecast alternate here in the office
and then I brought it home to try to do
that now I tried to reset profiles you
know by the time I spent about a half
hour doing and I said I need to get back
to testing this thing and not fiddling
around because clearly if it's not that
simple using Google's own Hardware
against itself within the same piece of
software there's something going wrong
here yeah I that's more of a chromecast
side in the Google home app but what do
you think's a part of it exactly that's
the founders edition you get the
controller and you get chromecast ultra
right so that that's part of the package
like this is the way you are going to
play stadia and also chromecast ultra
right now is the only way you can play
stadia in 4k yes and get the best image
quality so that is a big push for the
package and when
is widely complicated to get that all
set up not even mentioning the
complications when you try and do a
wired setup with chromecast ultra it's
it's too many too many hoops to jump
through for something that is pitched as
a simple way to just simply boot up and
get into a game real fast yeah I've
never seen a power brick have an
Ethernet port on it before yeah that's
this is just a practical physical
consideration and not exactly the
complications Michael was talking about
when connecting over Ethernet but for me
it was a very real issue because I'm at
home trying to work with a my setup you
know normally I plug in the end of an
ethernet cable into where the opposite
end of a power brick goes right into the
back of the console or whatever but in
this case I had to like rewire all my
stuff get the ethernet to where I would
plug in power that was kind of a
headache only to have it not work yep in
the end so for now I think that people
should know that
chromecast ultra has this weird issue
where if you're trying to set it up you
have to do it through a Wi-Fi network
through your phone first at first and it
has to be on the same network and if you
have the ethernet cable plugged in at
the same time it will not give you the
wireless signal you won't be able to
connect through the Wi-Fi network right
so there's a weird in-between where you
need to if you want to do a wired
connection through chromecast ultra it's
not clear like when you should be
putting in the wired connection for that
optimal experience because especially if
you're gonna be doing 4k with chromecast
ultra you're definitely gonna want to
rely on a wired connection right and we
need to talk about 4k but first I want
to say that like you know we do
understand that not every user is going
to be moving their chromecast Ultra
between different networks and between
different devices but these are just the
things we experience so it's definitely
worth mentioning in case you ever find
yourself in a situation where you might
want to do that but yeah regarding 4k
gameplay you know one of the things that
Google makes pretty clear when you're in
the settings menu to dial in the various
performance levels you want to put
stadia in 4k is going to take 20
gigabytes an hour of data that is a lot
and I don't think that that's terribly
surprising but it is expensive
I come close to my data cap or I go over
my data cap basically every single month
I'm captain a terabyte through Xfinity
I've had to shell out $50 to basically
unlock that in order just to test this
thing let alone use it as an actual like
mode of playing games on a regular basis
just to give you an idea of how much
data that is like I did the math out
there let's say you play on average
about three hours of games a day and
over the course of a month that's three
times thirty because about 30 days in a
month so that's 90 hours of game play
that's just a just a base estimate right
and multiply that by 20 you're coming
close to two terabytes worth of data
streaming 4k gameplay alone that's not
counting anything else that you do so
yeah that's that's a lot that's more
than you know a lot of data caps here at
least in the Bay Area is one terabyte
yeah I believe so I mean you're gonna be
going over that real fast so you do have
the option of knocking things down to
720p why would you want to do that I
think only for the sake of using the
more convenient features of stadia which
is you know streaming to your phone
which you can only do over Wi-Fi you can
- over cellular right now yeah and that
takes up four point five gigabytes an
hour which is more reasonable for sure
but again you're not really getting an
experience that is you know gaming the
way that you normally do right you're
playing last gen resolutions at that
point and we're on the cusp of next gen
consoles coming out of 4k being the
standard Google set in the past they
expect I speeds are just gonna do the
right thing and figure this out I hate
to tell you about ISPs like any other
business loves money yeah and if they
know that people like us are gonna ship
out money for more data they're probably
gonna take it and I did the Bay Area at
least where I live I don't have any
other option but to be slower than what
I currently have there Comcast which is
not an option yeah so all that said it
isn't all doom and gloom I do want to
talk about the controller really quick
this controller kicks ass it's really
really good yeah at least I think it's
reminiscent of the switch pro controller
in terms of the size and shape but it
has the layout of like a Dual Shock with
you know the two sticks down here inside
you know beyond that in terms of just
like an input device that you know in
terms of ergonomics and inputs this
thing does kind of work the way I
expected to you didn't really surprise
me and that was really good yeah I like
the control a lot the the sticks feel
smooth the d-pad I mean it may look
funny but like it has a nice crunch to
it the face buttons the triggers are
really a real nice and smooth as well so
overall it's it's a gaming control that
you would you know you kind of expect it
to be of this quality yeah so that's
great to hear one thing that is a little
disappointing though you know this the
founder Edition controller is something
that you've paid a premium for that
you're being sold as like this is a
collector's item that is exclusive to
this tier whatever well google also sent
a clip you know this is used to
basically attach your cell phone to the
controller so you can play the mobile
version of the game with full controls
which can be really good like playing
Tomb Raider for example a game like that
that has some looseness to its you know
control scheme and the demands it puts
on you as a player a little bit of
latency that I would get here and there
wasn't really a problem what is a
problem I think is that this clip that's
so tight has scuffed the heck out of
this controller ya know I don't have any
personal attachment to this as a
collectible but I could easily imagine
someone being disappointed to see that
that can happen now this isn't the only
clip that's gonna be on the market
obviously people are gonna sell more of
these maybe there's ones out there
they're gonna be designed with better
cushioning involved I don't know all I
know is this is the one Google sent as
the representative of the scenario that
you might use this in and it's
disappointing to see that they didn't
take the condition of the product that
they're actually selling and making in
you know into consideration okay well
let's talk about the games real quick
right now we've got Mortal Kombat up on
the screen and you said that you've been
playing a little bit of this I have as
well and a fighting game is one of those
things that is definitely going to make
you question you know the usability of
something like stadia right working in
the cloud latency is an issue fighting
games you obviously need to be very
responsive we are connected right now by
Ethernet so we've got a pretty good
connection and yeah why don't you you
know one of the things I found actually
if you don't mind is movies your cursor
around the screen to see like if it ever
sort of like hiccups or
lays or like gets multiple inputs when
you just hit it once yeah there's a
little bit of sometimes it hitches mmm
like it's in the middle of processing
your input but you know that that
happens not that often at least if
you're connected reliably right through
the internet but yeah and the reliable
connection you know that also has to do
with the bandwidth you're getting Google
recommends at least 10 megabits per
second down I assume in this environment
we have way more than that at home I
have about I think 500 megabits down and
yeah like playing wirelessly you know
was really responsive at home I remember
we were trying to do it on the wireless
network at the office for some reason is
not great and we were getting a ton of
input issues a ton of compression
artifacts but the moment I went home
they started playing on mobile
specifically over Wi-Fi is really good
and I thought like especially like again
I said to mater that worked out really
well
but of course you know you're not always
going to have a perfect connection and
in scenarios where I was dealing with
something you know just riding the line
between Google's recommended minimum I
was not happy with the experience so you
really need to have a fast connection
for stadia you know to work well and
that might not be surprising but it's
worth noting that their minimum is just
sort of like a technical minimum for it
to work not to be a great experience so
yeah you're playing Mortal Kombat we've
also played I think between us you know
a bunch of destiny to here and there
I've loaded up an old character I've
used the new one and it's been
interesting I think we've seen different
performance for destiny on different
platforms right like playing on mobile
it to me look just a lot like the
console version that's scaled down and
that's great I guess like it worked fine
there there's definitely some delay in
terms of moving the reticle and you know
inputs registering that made me have to
like reconfigure my approach to playing
so not ideal but again if we're just
thinking within the framework of cloud
gaming it's alright but when you were
playing on chromecast we noticed
something very unfortunate was that the
fov issue oh right yeah that that begs a
another question about the customization
with these games because you're not
getting like the PC versions of you
can't customize like its graphics
graphic fidelity that also means a game
like destiny too like you mentioned
there's no fov settings so right now if
you're playing in a like in a desk
situation where you're pretty close to
the screen a low fov is really gonna
like mess you up and I feel like when
you put it on the chromecast ultra and
it was running at 4k that if the fov was
actually narrower yeah the gun you were
using which is the it's that Egyptian
looking one what is it called Pharaoh's
shoot another one that gun took up what
looked like half the screen and you were
playing in 4k it what I mean we laughed
it was silly to look at and not this
sort of conditions you would want to
play destiny to in and yeah you know
it's not so here we go I mean that's
fine when you zoomed in but when we're
going yeah you can kind of get a sense
of it here yeah and yeah like like I
said you kind of want some of that
customization with with this with this
game especially if you're playing in
different settings like on console
you're probably playing in a couch
setting where you can kind of sit far
away from your TV and all that but the
nature of you know stadia where you're
switching between different different
modes of play you're gonna want to at
least have some sort of customization to
how the game looks now that being said
things could change we're not sure
because this is an evolving platform but
for now these are some of the
limitations that you have to think about
when playing these games on top of the
other
yes variables that you have to worry
about yeah I'm gonna pull up a doc here
and I'm gonna sort of run you through
you know the the things that are yet to
change once we start going here okay on
November 19th
the selection of stadia games their cost
the number of players on servers the
publisher side services of some games
the Google Assistant button Mortal
Kombat Elevens modes support for
wireless ps4 and Xbox one controllers
sharing captured content being able to
voice chat and seamless exiting of games
on mobile will be finalized yes
there's a lot that we have to check out
stick yeah which is ready yeah which is
kind of like why we're doing this sort
of as a review and progress is because
like we said in the beginning of videos
that we're working with an early version
of this even at launch it's still gonna
be a fairly early version of stadia it
these things - or this platform is going
to take time to mature yeah so and it's
evident in you know what you're gonna be
working with if you have a founders
Edition and also the list of features
that are yet to come
yes and so if you are someone who
pre-ordered the founders Edition or the
one that came after the premier Edition
which I think he can still pre-order
Google is going to be shipping those out
on a rolling per order basis so if you
got in early you might get yours - yeah
tomorrow the 19th when this officially
launches but it might take two weeks to
get according to Google so while you
potentially wait for yours and wait for
more opinions on stadia to come for us
we're gonna keep playing for now you
know we were shooting this last week by
the time you're watching this and
continue playing win the founders
edition and all those features go live
so taste you negate whoops so keep
coming back to GameSpot for more
coverage from myself and Michael thank
you for watching good luck Google we
hope it works out because honestly this
will be great if it did peace
[Music]